hey welcome to the second channel this
is a follow-up video to my main video on
public shaming so please if you haven't
watched that go watch it linked below
this is going to be a public shaming
Survival Guide because while I think we
should stop public shaming unless
something majorly changes with the
reward structures that we have on social
media I think we will continue to
publicly shame so I wanted to put
together a guide for if you are publicly
shamed maybe how to get out of it
because while the out level of outrage
is pretty similar across scandals how
people actually come out of it is
totally different you have people like
PewDiePie who seem to emerge unscathed
from their scandal and you also have
people like logan paul who their career
is largely tanked from their scandal or
at least seriously damage and everything
they do after that is judged by that
scandal so the first thing to understand
if you've been publicly shamed is that
you do need to apologize or somehow
clear up the controversy surrounding
your name but you need to do it in the
right way now making an apology is good
but as most people know who've seen
people make public apologies after a
controversy is a lot of times they don't
work and they don't work for very
specific reasons that we're gonna go
over the first reason is that anytime
you apologize to a group your your
forgiveness is gonna be fragmented
unless there's a representative for that
group who kind of speaks for everyone
and normally that doesn't exist online
right you can't you always have somebody
saying I don't accept it I don't accept
his apology and you have some people
saying I do accept this apology so what
you need to do is prop up someone who's
sort of the prototypical offended person
so to give you an example you have Bill
Maher who says the n-word on his show
and he gets in all sorts of trouble
here's the clip working the feet of that
sanic I'm a house pourraient of
criticism was unleashed at the comedian
whose brand is being politically acerbic
and outrageous DeRay McKesson a black
lives matter activist tweeting Bill
Maher has got to go
there's no explanations that make this
acceptable so what does he do
you've just said this thing on your show
that you're not allowed to say you have
Ice Cube on who is from NWA and he's
he's the guy if you had to pick a guy
that represents the voice of everybody
all the offended people he's the guy and
he goes on his show and he sort of
chastises him he says you know you're
wrong blah blah blah but at the end he
he says this it was wrong and I
apologized and you know that more than
that I can't do I accept your apology
when he actually forgives Bill Maher
it's sort of like he's forgiving for
everybody else too he's saying we've
moved on from this you know we're done
with this I'm done and we can laugh now
we can and this is the part of public
apologies that you can create that
one-on-one apology forgiveness
relationship rather than just appealing
to you know just anybody on Twitter this
is a great way to do it but it can
backfire because if you don't get the
right representative for the offended
group your controversy can continue so
if you look at Kevin Hart he tries to go
on Ellen after he's some homophobic
tweets get surfaced
I don't want to have to have this
conversation anymore because I Know Who
I am I'm not that guy I know you're not
that guy cuz I know you and you should
host the Oscars and I'm gonna talk you
into it after this great idea right
because she's gay
wrong because there's a better
representative for the offended that
Kevin Hart didn't apologize to Don Lemon
Don Lamont I really don't know how to
say that
after he apologizes to Ellen or sort of
tries to move past the controversy and
Ellen sort of forgives him or whatever
and says I believe in Kevin Hart I
believe in giving him second chances
what is done the Monti he said Don Lemon
say he says honestly Ellen doesn't speak
for the whole community and the reason
he can say that and it actually works is
because he is a better representative
I'm a gay man I don't know what it's
like to be I'm a gay black man I don't
know what it's like to be a white
lesbian I don't know so I feel obligated
to speak out on this issues I think
Kevin Hart's tweets were very clearly
directed at black men so the controversy
continues and Kevin Hart has to continue
this apology apology tour so if you do
not have the right representative of the
offended you're gonna kind of eat it you
got to get the right representative of
the offender but that's a really
powerful way probably the most powerful
way I've ever seen to get past a public
scandal is to find someone who
represents the offended to get on your
side and sort of theatrically represent
everyone else so secondly there's the
apology itself there's a lot of reasons
not to apologize as I've mentioned in my
video which I will link right here on
non apologies you know if it's unfounded
outrage if it's sort of built on BS then
actually apologizing can lea lend
credence to the very scandal itself and
sort of cement the scandal as a scandal
so there's reasons not to apologize but
there are also reasons to apologize if
there if there's founded outrage so if
you do decide to do that don't do a half
part of the apology there's so many
half-hearted apologies that continue
scandals well past their due date they
could have moved on but instead they
kind of give this flimsy apology that's
not really an apology so if you want to
know how to give a pitch-perfect apology
check out Nick Smith's
categorical apology I will link it down
below he goes over how to give the
perfect apology that will satisfy
everyone it's a great read to understand
the anatomy of an apology so I
recommend you go Reena finally an
apology will only work if you are
transparently sincere and this can be
really hard to prove unlike a
traditional apology where there's only
really one reason to apologize guilt
there's many reasons to make a public
apology for you know your brand for your
reputation for a job you may have lost
because of your scandal there's a lot of
competing reasons for why you'd maybe
fake an apology and as the audience we
don't want to be tricked we don't want
to be lied to and we sort of are very
skeptical of anyone who gives in a
public apology if there might be some
ulterior motives there the problem is is
if you haven't built the right rapport
with your audience and you aren't seen
as sort of a transparent trustworthy guy
you can't really build that trust in the
middle of your scandal so if you don't
have it you're not gonna be able to pull
this off you can see this with Logan
Paul where he messes up and he delivers
what is essentially a categorical
apology you know Nick Smith would
approve of this apology it has he takes
full blame he promises to be better he
you know names the people who are harmed
there's all these great things about his
apology but ultimately it falls on
totally deaf ears why because his entire
catalog of videos is him doing anything
for views so when he all of a sudden
seems to be super sincere and sensitive
nobody believes him you can see this
with the casein ice that interview where
Casey cannot get past this idea that
Logan Paul might just be faking it all
and trying to do Casey in to sort of set
up a Redemption arc for him and he
doesn't he's not having any of it my
very specific intention with this
interview was to see if he was sincere
or the whole thing is just a charade for
good PR I still I don't know is this a
fluff piece to make people feel better
about Logan Paul no like a [ __ ]
video it's just like look like you
should feel bad it's an unbiased
objective story maybe I'm being cynical
there's a little whiff of it sounding
like you see yourself in some capacity
as a Vick
no Logan Paul ends up just like kind of
spinning his wheels trying to prove
something that can't be proved once
you're already in a scandal which is
your honesty so that's really hard but
you can see the opposite of that with
someone like PewDiePie who delivers what
is essentially a very similar pitch
apology it you know takes responsibility
for his actions
shows regret all this kind of stuff that
Logan Paul did as well but ultimately
everyone forgives PewDiePie why because
he's built up the right rapport with his
audience to where people don't feel
duped and people feel like he probably
means what he's saying so this is a
really important part of surviving a
public shaming and a public scandal that
is sort of out of your control once it's
already happened so you should think
about building the right rapport with
people to be trustworthy before the
scandal breaks out so when it does you
can have a better shot of surviving
so to recap you need a representative of
the offended so your forgiveness isn't
fragmented this is the best way to get
out of a public scandal you also need to
give a categorical apology if that's
warranted otherwise you need to give a
non apology and I have a video on that
thirdly you need transparent sincerity
people need to believe you and believe
that you don't have ulterior motives
this is one thing you're gonna have to
prepare beforehand you can't do it once
you're in the middle of a scandal with
those three things if you do them right
you will survive your public shaming you
will get through it so this is a big
three there are a few side ideas I want
to discuss but that's the major things a
few side things might be though what you
have to realize when you're publicly
shamed is that there are two competing
narratives going on there's the one
you're trying to say that you're a good
person and all these things and there's
the second thing that's going on on
Twitter which is the worst caricature of
you as possible that's a second
narrative that's happening and your job
when you're being publicly shamed is to
stand strong on this first one or create
a third narrative you can see Logan Paul
trying to do this with what he's doing
with now he's now he's the suicide help
guy now he's the guy who's always
watching out for mental
health that's a third narrative he's
built because he knows his first
narrative of just being like this fun
goofy guy won't survive this second area
of him being a heartless you know a guy
who makes fun of suicide victims so what
does he do he builds this third
narrative like I'm helping out I'm a
changed man
excited eccentric cetera so it's all
about controlling your own narrative
that's one thing secondly if you're not
that famous maybe you don't have all the
resources to get a hold of these people
you can't get a famous representative of
the offended maybe you don't have the
right rapport people so a few ideas
they're number one you're in luck
because you're in less trouble news
stories don't get cliques if you're not
famous so it's unlikely your controversy
will continue for very long but if it
does hear a few ideas number one reach
out to journalists people love a
comeback story or a story of somebody
who's been misjudged so that's really
helped a lot of people people like just
justine sacco have been helped by
journalists like Jon Ronson who wrote a
book on her and basically saved her
career she was fired because for shaming
and now she was rehired because of this
like Redemption arc that was written
about her secondly get a reputation
fixer on Google I'll leave a link below
to one reputation fixer I can't vouch
for them personally but they're the
first thing that comes up I'm just
giving kind of like a case study that
there are these people out there they
will help your scandals go to the bottom
results of Google one of the big
problems with why scandals continue on
forever is because Google keeps serving
the scandal up over and over and over
even two years after it's done so those
are a few ideas on how to survive a
public shaming even if you're not famous
because it does happen to regular people
okay that's it thank you for watching
the second video I've tried to do this
thing where when I have leftovers from a
video because I do so much research on
these topics that things have to get cut
I want to kind of put them in a second
video on the second channel so those of
you who are interested in sort of a part
two or the kind of scraps of what may
have been cut from the main video can
still get it here it won't be as well
edited but at least you'll know about it
and you'll learn so thank you subscribe
to this channel if you haven't already
and I hope you
have any wonderful day
[Music]